um so I got to be real with you guys
you look like clowns oh five
years after Kim Kardashian slammed
Courtney and Chloe's fashion during a
trip to Japan the mom of four is getting
called out for rocking similar looks in
Tokyo yeah my book it's a great look
on Sunday the reality star shared a
series of snaps from her trip overseas
posing alongside her daughter's North
and Chicago in a gray crop top sweats
and an oversized pink furry coat with
matching purse I don't know what's gonna
top that and the coat looks a whole lot
like the one Chloe wore on a 2018 trip
to Japan that Kim famously mocked at the
time
um so I got to be real with you guys
you look like clowns oh
I'm not kidding this is not like
a tourist thing where it's like it's
Halloween dress up like a
Japanese geisha unless we're at a geisha
house
my hair looked good last night and I
thought my outfit was like fun for Japan
well five years later Kim's owning up to
those comments posting that clip to
Instagram along with a meme of a
side-by-side photo and a Fan's tweet
reading well well well Kim Kardashian
apologize now that I don't know Chloe
slid into the comments to let Kim know
I'm waiting Court also left a comment
with a playful dig a long way from the
cycling outfits referencing this clap
back to Kim's 2018 discs you think I
looked like a clown well you look like
you just won the Tour de France and
you're cycling around town you just
gotta roll with it and Kim she made it
right
sort of apologizing in the comments I'm
sorry Chloe and to court too
um so I gotta be real with you guys
you look like clowns oh Fashion
aside Kim's been documenting her family
trip to Japan with her kids North Saint
Chicago in Psalm on Tick Tock including
her sweet matching manicure with her
eldest
thank you
[Music]
the ladies opted for some cute Hello
Kitty nails which were on full display
in another clip where Kim North and
Kourtney Kardashian's daughter Penelope
shared some Hello Kitty treats grape
juice and ice cream we you know have
always stayed true to who we are and
always shared pretty much everything the
crew had dinner at a ninja themed
restaurant played with hedgehogs and
rats took a stroll to check out the
cherry blossom trees made their own
custom cup of noodles and visited Sanrio
where they took in lots and lots and
lots of Hello Kitty fun
everybody say Hello Kitty and that pink
coat that made quite a fuss turns out
Kim's got it in blue too it's giving
Cookie Monster realness and Kim we love
it
it means whole lot to me
I'm not telling you guys who to be or
what to wear or anything but I'm telling
you who to be and what to wear
foreign